hello everyone and welcome back to the
semi-finals of the opera euro rapid we
are in the second match
between magnus carlson and maxine vasher
lagrave the first match ended by
by maxine losing magnus one two games
one game ended in a draw
and now maxime needs to win the second
match to force tie breaks so this is the
second game
uh first game where maxime had the white
pieces send it in a draw and this is uh
quite a quite a lovely one so uh without
further ado
let's check it out uh magnus with the
white pieces
opens with e4 and you all know what that
means maxim goes for c5 he goes for the
sicilian defense
knight to f3 d6 and now d4 we have
captures captures
and knight to f6 knight to c3 and of
course maxim goes for his
neighbor of defense a6 the knight of
defenses on the board and magnus once
again goes for this queen to d3 line
that he already
uh used and it's uh uh it's not a
novelty or anything but i haven't seen
that it used on such a high level for i
don't know forever
uh so i i don't even know if it if it
bears any name
uh but you know for the purposes of uh
of this tournament we're gonna call it
the the magnus variation so queen to d3
uh and now knight b to d7 by uh by mvl
this is the
main way to proceed against queen to d3
and now bishop to a2 and bishop to g5
are no moves here but magnus goes for a4
uh counters this b5 move and uh it is
now
already as of move seven that we have a
completely new game
uh later on white can even grab more
space with a5 and really hinder black's
development so here
knight to c5 attacking the queen and the
e for pawn
and now the queen cannot go to g3 like
it did in um
in some other lines uh but a rather
queen to e3 you have to keep an eye on
this spawn
maxine goes e5 chases away the knight
knights the b3
and now just captures here and doubles
carlson spawn so captures captures
and now uh magnus had to capture it uh
not towards the center but uh
rather would see capture sun b
uh and now his pawn structure is a
little bit ruined so it's very
interesting to see
uh what what the idea behind this is and
maxime also wants to know he just
develops with temple bishop
attacks the pawn now we have bishop to
c4
asking okay now if you want to trade
you're just going to fix my pawn
structure so of course maxine not
interested in doing that
he just continues development bishop to
e7 and
castles by magnus and now rook to c8
with a double attack on the bishop here
so magnus defends it queen to e2 so
quite
quite the maneuvers with the queen queen
d3 queen e3 queen to
e2 now we have castles by maxine and now
rook to d1 just continuing development
we have queen to c7
now with a triple attack on this bishop
here uh
and bishop to g5 and here carlson's plan
is to eliminate the knight from f6 and
free up the d5
square for his uh for his knight even at
the cost of a pawn so bishop captures on
c4
b captures and now queen captures on c4
he gives up
one pawn but now comes queen to f3
and now what do you what do you play
here uh maxim won a pawn and he
now needs to figure out how to continue
and also you don't want to allow bishop
captures here because
then you're going to have to play g
captures or if bishop captures bishop
captures then you give up the d6 pawn so
maximum quickly goes back
queen to e6 uh this is the best way to
continue now everything is nicely
defended
but still bishop captures bishop
captures and knight to d5 so now magnus
is down upon
but he has a monster knight here on d5
and it's uh
none of maxine's pieces are going to be
able to contest this knight from from d5
so rook to c6 maxine prepares to double
up on the c
file and now rook the a3 by magnus
and now rook to b8 uh with ideas of
pushing this b
pawn he's not he lost interest in
doubling up on the c file
uh we have uh g3 by magnus uh making
some breeding room for the king
and bishop to d8 now so now the bishop
nicely controls the knight and maybe
later on in the future you can play some
like b5 bishop to b6 and so on
uh maxime would not mind trading this
bishop for for this knight
so a5 magnus stops that grabs more space
on the queen side here
and the g6 maximum also creates some
breeding room for the king
king g2 and now king to g7 both players
improve the position of their kings we
have
h4 and now h5 and now uh magnus just
pushes further with b4 so now magnus is
still down upon the batmax team still
without
any sort of a viable plan but he does
control the c file for the moment
so uh rook to c4 so what do you play
here
magnus doesn't go something like rook to
b3 or rook to b1
rather he goes to rook to c3 and uh
something something rather weird
happened here maxime captured carlson's
rook here
captures uh queen captures and then
played rook to c8 and uh magnus looked a
bit
uh weirded out by this move uh almost as
if uh he didn't even consider it maybe
he thought that he will now own the c
file but okay uh rook the c8 and now
queen back to d3
uh we rook to c6 uh and now rook to d2
we have queen to c8 now the queen and
rook battery is
operational under on the c file you can
now go for some uh
rook to c1 ideas maybe and now knight to
e3
so what what can black do here we have
b6 here maxine tries to bust open
uh this structure and maybe get his
bishop to this very nice b6 square so a
captures b
captures and now knight back to d5 but
now maxim just goes back
bishop back to b8 again nicely
controlling all of the squares the
knight can go to
we have queen to e2 now not allowing any
any any rook drops here and rook to c
for now
attacking this pawn here and also with
this uh he kind of blocks uh the queen's
attack to the a6 pawn but magnus attacks
it once again
rook to a2 uh and here comes queen to c6
and now uh he's saying okay what are you
going to do
everything is nicely defended uh if
anyone can do anything here it's black
but here magnus played something uh
really really impressive
even though he was only down to one
minute on the clock and maxim has some
nine minutes on the clock
magnus played rook captures on a6 and
we're definitely going to use this as a
thumbnail because it's super weird
magnus played rook captures on a6 and
now
uh what do you do here it seems like
it's a free rook but
is it a free rook well let's grab it and
see we have queen captures on a6
and now what was uh magnus's idea feel
free to pause the video
uh and try to find uh what he had in
mind or rather
uh better yet i'm just going to show you
he played knights to e3
attacking the rook and now the rook
cannot move but now is the
the actual time where you need to pause
the video so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find the absolute
best move for maxime here while i give
you a couple of seconds
uh so uh for those who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting uh
white's threat
white's threat of course is after the
rook moves uh he wants to play b5 and
then attack the queen under rook and win
back his material so obviously we're not
interested in that
what we're interested in uh is the move
bishop to a5 bishop to a5 with the idea
that now after
this rook is captured for example queen
captures queen captures the knight
captures
we simply pick up the pawn bishop
captures on b4 and we enjoyed this
position
uh being up upon and still pushing for
the win
however maxime did not go for this idea
maxime did play
rook back to c6 to defend his queen from
the white queen
and now magnus pushed b5 so
queen to a4 you have to give the rogue
back b captures
and now uh maxime needs to decide
whether to go for the e4 pawn or the c6
pawn he decides to grab the e4 pawn with
check saying that this is not a problem
the bishop covers the c7 square
magnus blocks this with check and now
queen to a4
so now magnus has a past c pawn and it
could be could be very dangerous we have
queen to d5
and bishop to d7 defending and blocking
we have knight to c4 with a double
attack on the pawn here
and now queen to b3 not allowing white
to capture because the queen hangs
and now magnus already as we said was
very low on time
uh decided to go for knight to e3 and
this is uh this is the
best way to play this you have to trade
and try and play the same game
so knight's the e3 and now of course you
cannot trade
if you if you trade then captures
captures the bishop has to move and then
you just play c7 and you win the bishop
and although black might be able to draw
this as he is up two pawns uh with
with perfect play white should be able
to win this so after knight to e3 we
have queen to a4 he declines the trade
and now queen to c4 again magnus offers
a trade but now maxime goes for it as
now he will
uh uh with waste some temp before for
this white knight so queen captures
knight captures now the knight will have
to waste a few more moves to get back to
that uh
c7 square uh king to f6 knights the a3
we have king to e7
knight to b5 attacking the bishop bishop
to b6 and now
magnus goes for c7 it looks weird
because the queen
the king can catch up to the past pawn
uh but it uh it's actually uh designed
to capture other pawns so here
king d7 and now magnus goes for c8
queen forcing maxime to capture it but
now knight captures on d6 with check
king d7 and knight captures on f7 and
with this maneuver
magnus trades down into a completely
equal end game
uh white uh white's pawn structure is is
intact and
a little bit better uh but it's it's not
much so king e6 uh we ignite to g5 check
king to f6 and king to f3 we have king
to f5 and now
knight to e4 we have king the e6 back
king to e2 uh we have bishop to d8 and
now king to d3 so neither player can
make progress with his king king d5
now f3 and now bishop to a5 knight f6
check we have king to e694 uh king goes
back we have knight to f6
king to e694 and king to d5 and he was
in this position
on a move uh 60 that magnus and maxine
agreed to draw so really really uh wild
stuff
and i think this game answered magnus
whether whether or not maxine was
prepared for this variation i mean of
course he's prepared because he saw
magnus
employ it at an earlier tournament so of
course he will have something ready for
this but
magnus couldn't achieve anything
throughout the entire game so
it's fair to fair to assume that maxim
has this uh all figured out so will
magnus uh try this once more
in game four or will he try something
else uh we'll see but uh either way he's
very satisfied with the draw he already
won the first day
so now even if he draws all the other
games uh he goes into the
finals so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it very exciting line of the
queen to d3 sicilian
i would like to thank uh no death man
louis burkhart david kimura
uh harry lewin and stephen hunt for a
contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the opera tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank y'all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day